start with Austin in Florida this hour
hey Austin welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show how can Chris and I help Dave and
Chris thank you guys for taking my call
today sure my question my question is me
and my wife for and baby step two and we
have $50,000 in debt also we have about
five credit cards and collections one of
those was Bank of America which they
actually sued us about two months ago of
a full amount and when they came to us
we try to denote negotiate but this is
actually their lawyers we try to
negotiate but they said it's too late
you know we're asking for the full
amount they even summed us
sheriff came to our house gave us the
papers along we have four other credit
cards in collections and my question is
should we tackle them so that we can go
XI or continue on our regular baby set
to debts that are that are good how much
do you owe B of a 3400 and what's your
household income 100,000 okay all right
and what is the rest of the debts you
got for credit cards and what else on
60k we have student loans there how much
we 30,000 30,000 we have a car loan for
12,000 and we Jack we actually just
settled with the timeshare exit team we
got out of our timeshare good but we're
we're having to pay them approximately I
think we have ten thousand dollars left
so we got a payment plan with them to
complete that process okay good but you
got an end to that mess so they're bad
news okay so the sheriff came and served
you with a court order or gave you a
date right yes which has actually been
extended because of the coated so when
is the winners the date the new date I
believe is
June 15th but we thankfully we we got
our stimulus check which is exactly what
we needed for it so we put that in
savings I've tried to contact a lawyer
to pay them but they're unavailable just
due to the virus
don't pay them don't pay them at all
nope nope I would show up down there at
on June 15th and meet with the attorney
and they will settle it on the spot with
you and you'll get it for 50 cents on
the dollar 20 cents on the dollar okay I
expected it yeah yeah you're broke you
don't have any money and you know you
don't have the money to pay this in full
that's why you were offering them a
settlement forgot 6sy sand collection to
start with and here's what happens
you're dealing when your deal with Bank
of America to start with you're dealing
with Satan but did I say that out loud
but anyway the but the you know when you
go when you're dealing with their
attorneys in collections you are a
widget in a factory that churns out
5,000 widgets a minute all day long so
there's absolutely no you got no
attention at all when you try to work
with them before you are probably
dealing with a 26 year old paralegal at
best okay when you what when you trot
down there what you're gonna find is the
attorney has a two wheeler with boxes of
cases that are going before the judge
all at once that day they're rolling the
widgets off the end of the assembly line
and you're one of them when you actually
show up in person it is so completely
shocking to them that they cannot
emotionally deal with it and then just
stand up before the judge and tell the
judge I offer them a settlement if they
won't settle but he'll settle before you
just find the little character and he'll
be running around he'll be highly
unimpressive because he can't get a good
job right and you know his little his
little mustache will be going up and
down with cookie crumbs in it
something right I'm telling you you're
gonna be so underwhelm you've been to
traffic court
oh yeah luck for a speeding ticket
remember when you went you thought it
was a big deal and then when you got
down there it's almost like something on
a Saturday Night Live skit you remember
that that's what the emotional part with
me too is you know yeah go on a court
for something well that's my point you
when you went to traffic court though
you were all jacked up about it
but when you got down there it was
almost funny wasn't it the way it all
went down to do what it was quick to it
was very quick and it was just like it
was automatic and the judge goes oh you
want to go to school or you wanna pay
the ticket if you go to school comes off
your insurance and go school your honor
everybody says school your honor right
and you run through the school you know
how it works and so this is about the
same thing this is a traffic ticket
world and they're just and and nobody
comes you'll probably be the only one
there yeah awesome they see you as an
account number and a dollar amount and
so for you to go down there and to be
firm and to be clear what it is is now
you're putting a name to your to your
account number but just you know get
give them payment that you have proof of
payment has been made if you cut a deal
and then he has to give it to you in
writing that it is settled or in a greed
order will be fine before the judge give
it in turn agreed order that they agree
to accept a thousand dollars for this
thirty four hundred and you can take
cash if you want I don't care but needs
to give you a receipt so for the other
four same thing just continue just
continue to work them over the phone
like you work these guys I'm surprised
you were unsuccessful over the phone as
you were but you're dealing with Bank of
America seriously is so standard in the
credit industry when something gets all
the way to court like this that
something hundred ten thousand dollars
are settled for about fifteen to twenty
cents on the dollar yeah it's done every
day well and I'm like out of the house
here to know sometimes if that debt gets
shifted to a collection company that may
not be a bad thing yeah because you get
an opportunity now to deal with some
people that may talk with you and work
with you just make sure that they're
documenting your account that you write
down the name and number of who it is
you're speaking with they may tell you
their name is Bob that's not there
because they're gonna have 17 different
one used to call me was mrs. Savage and
another one was Baskerville like the
hounds of yeah that's that's being they
make up they make up pseudonyms yeah to
be into savage the bounds of Baskerville
or after you Dave what's that caught
onto how those stupid business works it
got to be human because they can't play
with your emotions well yeah because I
was scared out of my brain no I thought
I thought I was some kind of deadbeat
and I wasn't I was just a guy who
screwed up so clean it up dude you can
go down there if you want if you want
just write him a check you can write him
a check but I I think it's in a little
bit of an adventure I think it's
probably worth a couple grand a couple
grand to you if you go down there sit
down meet the guy with the cookie crumbs
in his mustache I'm promise you you're
gonna find a highly unimpressive
individual because they could not get a
job doing something else so they're
doing small $3,400 credit card suits for
Bank of America good lord that's the
bottom of the barrel